almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it so you have
to see this video to believe it Sean
Hannity from Fox News is promoting a
pepper spray and tear gas gun on his
live nightly television program here in
the United States if you don't know we
have a propaganda news channel called
Fox News and with some rare exceptions
Fox News basically carries water for
Republicans and significantly carries
water for Donald Trump
yesterday Sean Hannity promoted a
projectile gun powered by co2 cartridges
which shoots balls of pepper spray and
tear gas now this is considered a
chemical weapon that is banned in
international warfare I'll talk about
that a little bit later check out the
video from Sean Hannity's program etho
methods that the police could do take a
look at your screen look at that I by
way no Fey in the financial interest in
burn a gun but I purchased a number of
them yes full price I paid now I met
with them yeah and I purchased the
number of their items now again this is
a an alternative it won't kill people
non-lethal defense non-lethal it shoots
small projectiles filled with pepper
sprayed tear gas and by the way unlike
these Thun guns which have an incredibly
short range and the stupid wires this
weapons accurate up to 50 feet why
because I own one and even come equipped
with lasers so you can't really miss for
accuracy now we didn't show the video I
wanted to we'll get it up later in the
show where it actually will play for you
what happens when it when you somebody
gets it with it they don't die and say
it could hopefully be an alternative in
a very volatile dangerous situation
whatever new technology we can develop
now according to report I like how
Hannity clarifies that he doesn't have
an investment in the manufacturer burna
which would be the natural thing we
would imagine because it sounds and
looks like an infomercial happening in
the middle of his program
it sort of sounds like the context is
he's trying to propose ways that police
could deal with protesters to avoid
hurting them or maybe for police to deal
with encounters like the George Floyd
encounter so I played this for you for
two different reasons first the visual
of it is crazy
it looks like an infomercial Hannity is
promoting specific weapons on his
program which is a wild thing for news
programs to be doing
he's also spreading misinformation
Hannity is promoting this like it's a
paintball gun which by the way if you
get hit in the eye with a paintball gun
it can still do damage but if you get
hit in the eye with a pepper spray or
teargas ball you could not only lose the
eye there can be very serious reactions
to pepper spray and tear gas even on the
basic facts Sean Hannity is acting like
this is like a harmless tool when it is
not at all harmless there are
international case reports of tear gas
causing death through eventual
respiratory failure and there's other
just horrifying examples and in the
context of coronavirus one of the things
you're not supposed to do is touch your
eyes and you want to try to avoid
coughing and sneezing on other people
when you deploy tear gas and pepper
spray in large crowds people immediately
start rubbing their eyes coughing
sneezing onto the people next to them so
this is a bad idea in general it's a
particularly bad idea now with
coronavirus and in studies done on
members of the military were very often
they will be exposed to tear gas as part
of their training it increases your risk
of contracting the flu pneumonia
bronchitis and other respiratory
illnesses so this is not without
consequence as Hannity is trying to
argue next tear gas is considered a
chemical weapon and it's banned in war
dating back to 1993 now you might say
okay it might be banned internationally
but the United States isn't part of that
yes it is the United States ratified the
ban on these tools weapons in 1997 but
domestically tear gas instead of being
considered a banned chemical weapon is
considered an approved riot control
agent and it's permitted for law
enforcement use it is actually so common
in the United States that people may not
realize tear gas is banned in
international warfare and we have
American law enforcement using it for
crowd control and compliance during
domestic protests which are protected by
the First Amendment banned on the
battlefield used regularly in American
cities
so that's layer one and layer two now
the deeper issue here
Hannity like many people on the right
comes at all of these issues with the
attitude of what gun or weapon or
aggressive tactic could we introduce
into a situation that's already volatile
that's how they approach these issues
they never go to how could we
de-escalate a situation to prevent
officers from even needing or believing
that they need
tear gas guns to begin with this is the
problem and when when police bring out
tear gas into a chaotic situation it
creates more chaos and the protests
become more chaotic and it leads to even
harsher reactions from police this is a
completely optional self-reinforcing
feedback loop the de-escalation tactics
like you know transparent communication
empathy negotiation we've seen examples
of all of this stuff that's how you stop
the cycle of escalation
instead Sean Hannity is talking about
here's a tear gas gun you could use and
apparently it's within law enforcement
big picture to understand that the
priority should rather than being better
armed with riot shields and night sticks
should be de-escalation tactics and this
is a big part of the police reform that
I've been outlining over the last few
days on the show